- Negativity from a human
is literally probably the worst thing
another human can do to another human.
And normally, it's your mom.
(upbeat music)
(cheering)
- [Gary] You've got your perspective.
(audience cheering)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(mellow beats)
(upbeat string plucking)
- Could definitely, clearly see
that your content was way different
and just, after a couple months after,
I was just, I was fed up.
I quit my job.
I just decided I wanted to be a
YouTuber.
- [Gary] Makes sense.
- [Dustin] And then, I
just wanted to pursue that
'cause I just was like-
- [Gary] Fuck it.
- Yeah, seeing that, and I remember seeing
Jim Carrey's graduation speech,
and seeing how if you don't
like what you're doing,
why don't you try something that-
I forgot what exactly he said,
- The punch line is right.
I mean, I have no idea.
I saw Caleb, in the corner
of my eye, shake his head,
so, obviously this video is seen a lot
and I think I do remember something.
It doesn't matter, here's the punchline.
While everybody's watching, too.
It makes the most sense in the world
to go high risk in your youth.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you can live
in your parents' house.
You, too, and 19 people watching,
can live in a studio, 21 deep.
What do you think immigrants do?
- True.
- They live 21 deep in a fuckin' studio.
- Yeah.
- Like, I fucking know it.
I lived it, I saw it.
I watched it.
This is exactly when you
guys are supposed to take
two core leaps of faith.
Either go fuckin' do it for yourself,
or, get close to something
that you believe in completely,
and if it's more about content, like me?
Cool, that makes sense.
Now, Alex is watching,
This makes sense for you guys.
Because, by the way,
I'm lookin' at all three of you right now,
you might not be entrepreneurs.
It's hard.
It's different, it's a talent.
But, cool, then get as close
as possible to something
that's awesome, rad, or
fun, or entrepreneurial,
whether that's a human skateboarding.
Go and fuckin', link up,
go DM right now, or email,
or hit up on YouTube message,
the 17 coolest skateboarders
that you think,
and be like, "I will
work for you for free!"
If you're privileged in two ways.
There's two privileges.
There's the privilege of:
Your parents can help you.
Great, that's fine.
That's not bad.
Then, just own it.
Don't be like, you're doing it.
It's about truth.
Or the privilege of humility.
- Yeah.
- The privilege of loving to eat dirt.
The privilege that your
mindset is so right,
that when the skateboarder's like,
"Cool, come to Malibu."
You're like, "Oh, fuck. Uh, okay."
Go on Craigslist, be like, "Yo",
and then also work a
Burger King night shift.
The privilege of humility.
Either be the skateboarder
that has a fuckin' blog,
or go work for the skateboarder.
Or, next, go and fuckin'
what you do for me,
what you three do for me,
DM on Instagram, right now,
the coolest skateboard shop or brand,
and be like, "I produce amazing content
"for YouTube and Instagram."
I have a funny feeling,
that if every fuckin' kid
who's watching this video
right now, DM's 13 companies
or people that they think are rad,
with the "I make amazing content
for Instagram or YouTube."
They're gonna find themselves
a very interesting reply.
That's my 2018 challenge.
DM 13 fuckers that you think are awesome,
or companies, right?
And tell them that you make
awesome content on Instagram
and YouTube and see what the fuck happens.
Change the course of people's lives.
If they have the privilege of,
And, by the way, there's
a third privilege.
You sold a ton of fuckin'
tchotchkes on eBay
and saved up 10,000 bucks,
and you can go to fuckin' Oakland,
and live for four-and-a-half
months, 'cause you earned it.
'cause you went on Craigslist free,
and flipped it on Face...
It's all here.
So fuckin' proud of you, man.
- Thanks.
- Do you know how many people
sit in that IT job for their life?
- Yeah.
(electronic tonal music)
♪ Came up, came up ♪
♪ Is it obvious to you ♪
♪ That I'm way up, way up ♪
♪ Off of drama I don't need ♪
♪ Could you stop that, stop that ♪
♪ I was only... ♪
- Hey, guys, hi.
- Hi.
- Nice to meet you. Hello.
- Hi, nice to meet you.
Ready to go?
You guys good?
- Yeah.
- We're rolling.
(rap music)
- Good.
Hey, everybody.
How are you?
- Good.
- Great.
The biz ops project management thing is
interesting to me.
(slow music)
You really made an impact here
- Yeah.
and a lot of people took notice.
- I try to.
- You got a lot of fans out there.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm impressed.
- Yeah, I try to.
- You did it.
- Yeah.
- It's not that easy to do, by the way.
You made a real impact.
- Yeah.
- So, now what?
- Now, I go back to school.
- And what is school?
- UC Irvine.
California.
- Yup.
- How long?
- I'm gonna go into my sophomore year.
- You're a kid.
- Just turned 19, yup.
- Is it harder now because this is such
- an anti-college environment?
- yes
- Yes. It's harder to go back.
I didn't really pay much attention.
And now, I'm just like--
nah
- fuck
- Yes, now, it's even worse.
- Now it's like you can't even un-see it.
- Yeah, I know.
- I know.
But you can go a different route.
If you want to make your parents happy.
You can just turn it into a vacation.
- Yeah, yeah.
- For real.
- That's what I'm ... yeah.
- Just don't fail out.
- (laughs) Makes sense.
- Ya, like if Gary Vee
is coming an hour away,
and giving a talk and you're
interested in that, go.
If Casey does an impromtu
popup meet and greet
and you want to go
and you have to miss
Science, miss Science.
Do you understand?
- Yeah, okay.
(techno music)
- This is us huh?
- [Audience] This is us, yep
(techno music)
- Learning how to make
money online can be tricky,
which is why I wanted
to put out an article
that can be a resource for
anyone and everyone looking
to make a few hundred extra bucks a week,
as opposed to...
$100 into 1,000,
or even 10 into 1,000,
I am going to teach you how
to turn zero into 1,000.
For what feels like the last 30 years,
hundreds of people have told
me that they can't pursue
their new business idea or personal brand,
or even flip stuff online
because they have no money to get started.
The worst part is, despite
hating excuses with all my heart,
I've always had to pander to that response
because of the lack of-
- I've always had to have
sympathy and empathy for them
(people talking and laughing)
- However that is no longer an excuse.
For the first time in my career,
I've eliminated the
excuse of having no money.
It's called Craigslist free section.
Then it goes over steps
on how to flip stuff...
(woman talking)
- You feeling good about it?
- Yeah.
So sure it may take you 87 minutes
to make that extra 20 bucks,
but trust me that's a whole lot better
than doing whatever it is
that you're doing otherwise.
I seriously cannot get this
opportunity out of my -
- Make a context there of,
if you're complaining,
- Yes
- for a lot of people
you don't need 100 bucks,
but you need to hedge there a little bit.
- Cool
- Do you understand?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
(cars honking)
- Then that's essentially it,
here's all the people that are killing it.
It shows tweets, it shows
tweets of people complaining.
Good?
- Good.
- Cool, thanks man.
(cars honking)
(slow music)
- How do I get in the back?
- Just pull the bar.
- That's probably my biggest
issue at hand, right?
With so much to do.
Like where does this even sit?
What does it, for example,
when I see it, I'm like "what
does that even require of me?"
(slow music)
Oh god
(laughing)
They all sound so great in theory
but then it's just so
much energy and work.
Right?
So underestimated how
much energy goes into it.
You know?
- I just wanna say, I know you deal
with a lot of entrepreneurs,
artists, and all that.
I'm a poet, you don't
talk a lot about poets
but you have helped me
- No.
- immensely.
I went from sharing random
stuff here and there
in little basements, to making
money from going to shows
and open mics and doing
shows because of you.
Because of being consistent with my craft.
- Yes.
- It's only been
a couple years of doing it.
And I watch you so often.
You remind me of my dad
who has that immigrant hustler story,
he came here with no money.
I showed my dad your videos
and he started crying,
like he loves you.
- (laughs) That's amazing
- No I'm serious
- Thank you.
Tell him thank you.
- And you know,
you just meant so much to me.
- What's your name?
- Nerali
- And also you put me on to a -
- Yes.
- You love Sierra, I'm from Philly,
- Yes
- So many connections
- We got flavor together
- I knew, genuinely
you have meant so much to me.
- Thank you so much
- I mean that's just a couple things.
I could go on
- Thank you so much.
Thank you
- Thank you (laughs)
- Photo?
for one second
- We have field passes
if you want to go now
- Yeah, I want to go,
when do we have to leave?
- Relatively soon, not immediately
- 30?
20?
- Probably 30 at the latest
- It's six. 6:30?
- Probably 20, 30.
- 20 minutes? Okay.
- Cool?
Cool with it?
- Yeah
- We came all the way from
Arkansas because we love you
so much and we just wanted
- thank you so much
to thank you for the
content that you put out
and it's completely
changed both of our lives
and the way we act, what
we do in our business,
in our job, in our every day life.
Just wanted to say thank you.
- Thank you so much for coming out here
- We started an electrical
contracting company, WomenO
- WomenO in New York City
- Love it, love it
- And we want to ask you from contracting,
how is it different, how can
you bring it up and make it-
- What's the best way?
- One more time, I want to make sure,
for what kind of contract?
- Construction.
- Electrical contracting
- So are you thinking
from a sales standpoint?
Or from a marketing standpoint?
- Well, I know you're more
into...both, everything
- To me, this is why I ask,
you notice how I don't ask that often?
I think the business you're
in is more predicated
on sales up front than it is branding.
- Interesting.
- I kind of disagree but,
- Great,
- I'll go with it
- I'll go with it,
- that's amazing
- I never think I'm always right,
and more importantly I always think--
- What would you do if you were us?
- I would do sales
- 100% sales
(laughing)
- I would do sales up front
- How would you do sales?
- Knock, knock, knock, alright.
- I don't--
- That's what we do
- More
- Right
- Even more
- Okay
- Got it?
- You spending one minute on one video
or how you're gonna
brand position yourselves
as female leaders is one minute
away from sales
- Interesting
- That's why I'm giving you the answer,
I know it's a counter
answer to my normal advice,
- Interesting
- but I believe your business up front,
establishing through sales, a foundation,
is outrageously important.
My point of view
- Yeah
in watching a lot of construction
businesses being built,
- Listen, Gary
- And general contractors
- Thank you
- But you know, I know
it's super counter to
what I normally say,
- Yes (laughs)
I would never say that actually
- but this is why I
always want to meet people
- I felt like crushing it to get there
- I get it, but that's
why context matters,
that's why I do this
- Yes
- 'cause I curve ball when
I know all the details
- Awesome
- If you can get a couple,
if you can get a nice
little business going
with a foundation, then
you can take the risk
of branding down.
- Interesting
I didn't brand Bender
Media at first, I did sales
- Ah hah
- Yes, that's how he did
- Understand?
- When you're doing that kind of business,
especially in your sector,
- Oh yeah
you gotta reverse engineer your customer.
Your customer will respond to sales.
- Right, fantastic, love it.
- Thank you so much
- You got it
- You're welcome.
- Thanks again
- Alright, who wants to sneak one in?
- Friend negativity, from friend issues--,
- Can't hear it
- who's cheating on who
- If I walk home tonight and
my wife is cheating on me,
I can deal with that easy,
- Yeah?
- Easy.
- Alright.
- Yeah, okay.
- Easy, I'll tell you why.
I'll tell you why.
First thing I would do, like
I do everything in my life,
I would look at myself.
First.
- Take responsibility.
- 100%.
Walk in with a man and
my wife and I'd be like,
"there's so much of what I've
done to create this moment."
I believe that, you may not believe me,
you just don't know me.
I believe it with all my heart.
- Yeah
Friend negativity is
easy, I don't hear it.
Like I love my friends,
but if they're negative,
my friends being negative
only leads to me spending
less time with them, but I
won't cut them out completely if
I grew up with them.
- Yeah
- If they're my homies,
but I'll hang out with them once a year.
I'll be there for them,
but negativity from a human
is literally, probably,
the worst thing another human
can do to another human.
And normally it's your mom.
(people laughing)
- Thank God it's not.
you know, and so
it's your mom 50% of the time.
Think about how crazy that is
(people laughing)
so, that's easy bro,
only because that's on me
- You can limit your time with your mom,
you can limit your time
with your best friend.
You can tell your girlfriend
or husband to go fuck themselves.
- Yes
- You could.
You're accepting to be
in that relationship.
That's on you.
- Yeah
I feel like even when I give it away
and I don't speak to them,
the chatter of them talking,
it gets layered.
- That means you value their opinion
- Yeah
- I don't.
(people chatting)
- If you're cutting them
out 'cause they're negative,
in theory you don't value
their opinion, but you do.
You're doing it as a tactic,
you're not all the way there yet
- 'kay
- That's what you need to look at
- Yeah
- It means that you might believe that.
I don't.
- Group photo?
- Group photo? All
right, real fast, get in
quick group photo lets
go, group photo quick
(people chatting and laughing)
- Of course we're not going to fit in
- Get in ladies, Caleb knows what to do
(laughing)
("Same Villa" by Villa)